[Music]
by now you're probably familiar with
mrna vaccines they're the ones most
commonly used in the u.s against covet
but scientists think this technology can
do a lot more like targeted disease you
may have heard of too lyme disease which
is spread by ticks some have called it a
silent epidemic one that's been growing
between 2018 and 2019 alone the number
of cases went up about four percent
let's take a close look at how this new
experimental shot works and why it could
be a game changer if it gets approved
for humans
each year about 30 000 cases of lyme
disease are reported to the cdc but the
actual number may be as high as nearly
half a million to understand what those
numbers mean for patients i called up
brian fallon a lyme disease expert at
columbia university
if you don't catch it detect it early
it can lead to a variety of serious
problems it could lead to
neurological problems such as meningitis
facial palsy chronic cognitive problems
it can lead to psychiatric problems
depression irritability etc brian said
that even with antibiotics some patients
end up with these long-term debilitating
symptoms it's similar to in some ways
the
long covet syndrome we've had long lyme
syndrome for a long time but now it's
widely recognized that microbes can
cause these persistent symptoms and lead
to these persistent symptoms brian isn't
part of the team that's developing the
new vaccine but like other lyme experts
he thinks we need something novel and we
need something new in the fight against
lyme disease and this definitely
offers that promise
mrna isn't the only thing that makes the
vaccine novel most vaccines help the
body attack a pathogen that causes the
disease for covid that stars kovi too an
mrna vaccine like the one against covid
varies orders an mrna molecule into our
cells those mrna instructions are for
making a harmless version of the viruses
spike protein our cells then make that
protein which spurs the immune system to
build up defenses against it and the
virus not so with this new mrna lyme
disease vaccine whose development
preceded the pandemic by years
researchers have been developing mrna
technology for decades errol figgrick
the yellow researcher who was working on
the vaccine told me it targets 19
proteins in deotek saliva instead of the
bacterium that actually causes lyme
disease so this is a new way of
developing vaccines when a deer tick
bites it latches on and feeds for days
errol told me it takes about 36 hours
for borrelia burgdorferi the lyme
disease causing bacteria to make its way
into a person as the tick is feeding if
you can prevent the tick from feeding
early on
you have a good chance of preventing
lyme disease his vaccine which hasn't
been tested in humans does that in two
ways first it creates a kind of alert
system that's important because the tick
bite doesn't itch the way a mosquito
bite would so it often goes undetected
allowing for silent transmission so our
goal is to make it easily recognizable
that recognition signal is redness on
the skin where the tick is feeding the
redness is the earliest hallmark
associated with acquired tick resistance
this redness is different from the rash
that some patients develop when they get
lyme disease it's part of the immune
system's attack on the lyme
disease-causing bacteria guinea pigs
immunized with aryl's three-dose mrna
vaccine and then bitten by deer ticks
two weeks after their last dose
developed this immune-driven redness as
you can see here it appeared about 18
hours after the ticks latched on errol
said that if people react similarly to
the vaccine they'd be more likely to
notice they've been bitten and they
could immediately remove the tick before
the bacteria it was carrying had a
chance to infect them but even if a
person missed that red alert the vaccine
could still help fend up ticks and lyme
disease transmission that's because the
immune response that produces against
tick saliva helps stop the ticks from
feeding just like you eating a meal that
was too hot or a drink that was too hot
ticks that latched on to vaccinated
guinea pigs ate less and they fell off
their host sooner all this amounted to
protection from infection with the
bacteria that causes lyme disease none
of the researchers 16 vaccinated guinea
pigs tested positive for the bacteria
after they were bitten whereas nearly
half of the unvaccinated ones did
[Music]
so far this mrna vaccine has only been
tested in guinea pigs and mice next up
is testing in other animals including
primates the goal is to eventually test
it in humans before covid vaccines
normally took about 10 years from start
to uh clinical development kovit has
shown us that's possible in
a year
really remarkable i don't think that
five years is a unrealistic expectation
maybe sooner maybe a bit later when
errol and his lab started working on
their shot years ago mrna vaccines were
still an unproven technology but kovit
has changed all that we now know that
mrna vaccines are very effective plus
the fact that this vaccine targets the
animal that spreads slime means it could
be helpful in fighting other diseases
spread by deer ticks and even other
ticks that could translate into fewer
jabs and more protection for us
i found this story through someone i
follow on social media if you have ideas
for cool research i should cover please
leave it in the comments and while
you're at it subscribe to my channel
that means hit subscribe hasta la
proxima